c'est à l'espace rédelé à saint denis
que s'est déroulée la business garden
mis en place par pôle emploi réunion 70
entreprises du secteur nord est est été
conviés pour un échange privilégié avec
le pôle emploi et ses partenaires sur
les dispositifs d aide au recrutement
l'organisation de cette manifestation
aujourd'hui parti d'un constat c'est que
au niveau de nos employeurs
quand on des échanges avec nos
employeurs on a vu qu'il avait un besoin
ces échanges et donc sur nos dispositifs
sont aux aides et mesures
et souvent quand on met en place et à
deux mesures il nous poser des questions
donc sur les autres démarches
administratives donc qu'il fallait faire
pour pouvoir donc finaliser la mesure
donc l'objectif de cette rencontre
c'était sur un même lieu
réunir donc tous les partenaires afin
d'aider l'employeur à simplifier ces
démarches administratives et en même
temps satisfaire les besoins de
l'entreprise en matière de recrutement
un véritable moment d'échangés entre les
agences et les entreprises les
employeurs ont pu trouver sur place
toutes les informations concernant les
mesures allant bosch ou encore la
simplification des recrutements et des
démarches administratives la cgss je
veux expliquer aux chefs d'entreprise
que là on est un organisme qui est aux
côtés des entreprises que ça soit pour
l'emploi pour les cotisations
l'utilisation de l'offre de services
dématérialisés tout cela est donc
expliquer à notre stand à la la mesure
phare qui lui offrait cette année c'est
la déclaration sociale nominative de
l'adsl il faut qu' il faudrait que tout
entre tout employeur face à la dsn dans
le courant de cette année 2016 et il
faudrait pas que l'employeur vous donc
le coche aujourd'hui l'équipe de la
plateforme de vocation est présente pour
présenter la mairesse qui est la méthode
de recrutement par simulation est donc
le but de la méthode de recrutement par
simulation c'est d'évaluer des candidats
est de mettre les candidats en situation
de montrer qu'ils sont des habitués des
capacités cd comprend tournant fait le
cd1 le but de la méthode c'est vraiment
de donner la possibilité aux personnes
de montrer qu'elles ont du potentiel
à travers des mises en situation une
manifestation qui a réuni tous les
interlocuteurs sur un même site un
véritable gain de temps pour les
employeurs alors il se trouve que notre
cabinet on a un certain nombre de
clients employeurs bien évidemment et
qu'ils nous croient souvent des
questions concernant les aides que ce
soit au recrutement que ce soit en
termes de financement des postes
salariés
donc en fait je suis venu ici pour
m'informer pour compléter ma formation
en termes de dispositifs pour être
pertinent par rapport à mes clients
c'est important dans un premier temps de
le faire et dans un même temps de l'es2
rassembler tous les interlocuteurs
un rendez vous réussi pour les
entreprises et pôle emploi
une matinée des changes qui a permis aux
employeurs de trouver toutes les
informations dont ils avaient besoin
pour recruter